et voilà c'est l'heure de notre second
débat évidemment tout de suite vous le
savez il est volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour on prend du recul
alors ce soir on a choisi d'analyser la
crise du spectacle vivant en France on
va beaucoup parler du théâtre des
laissés par les spectateurs mais d'abord
l'exemple de l'Opéra l'Opéra Bastille
qui s'ouvre depuis 5 ans à des familles
pour leur première fois à l'Opéra Jérémy
Hansmann
ce dimanche à l'Opéra Bastille souffle
un air de découverte
6e niveau par les ascenseurs la plupart
de ces familles entre ici pour la
première fois
ça représente
un monde un peu
[Musique]
comme les galinons venus spécialement
d'Aveyron pour l'occasion pour
tous les
familles de 4 tout on est également dans
un emplacement privilégié 25 euros par
adulte 10 euros par enfant des tarifs
très accessibles pour découvrir Tosca et
avant la représentation certains ont
même pu en savoir plus sur le
chef-d'oeuvre de Puccini Tosca veut
libérer cavarade aussi elle va donc voir
scarpilla le chef de la police pour lui
demander de libérer cavarade aussi grâce
à ses échanges avec des personnels de
l'Opéra on note avec le metteur en scène
et ses équipes tout ce qui va être le
fil conducteur du spectacle
Ivan Augusto et le régisseur général de
production il travaille en coulisse
caché aux yeux des spectateurs
normalement je suis branché au casque
directement avec tous les services qui
vont intervenir sur scène donc là on
voit les normes machineries le jeu la
lumière le son vidéo les régies et donc
au fur et à mesure de l'avancée de la
musique que je donne les top à tous les
personnes qui vont intervenir sur scène
je le deuxième chef d'orchestre les
cloches retentissent mesdames et
messieurs début de la représentation de
toscas dans 30 minutes de préparez-vous
merci dans la salle plus de 1000
personnes sélectionnées découvre
aujourd'hui l'Opéra
[Musique]
une œuvre chantée en italien pas de quoi
effrayer les enfants nombreux et déjà
captivés
c'est assez simple à comprendre j'aime
bien les musiciens
et puis
j'aime bien comment elle chante c'est
magique
[Musique]
au total plus de deux heures de
représentation longuement salué
et à la sortie des familles qui semblent
avoir apprécié l'expérience la mise en
scène les champs les décors c'était
vraiment impressionnant j'ai trouvé ça
long donc je pense pas revenir plusieurs
fois mais une ou deux fois je pense si
j'ai l'occasion en tout cas s'il y a
encore ce genre de de d'offres
sinon je sais pas si je pourrais faire
revenir les spectateurs et diversifier
son public c'est justement l'enjeu de
l'Opéra national de Paris pour les
années à venir on a 18% de spectateurs
qui qui sont qui ont moins de 28 ans par
an donc c'est un public important mais
on a aussi beaucoup de personnes qui
sont un peu plus âgées et l'idée c'est
de maintenir et de renouveler ce public
le frein ce n'est pas pour moi il y a
des codes c'est pour des gens qui
connaissent ou pour des gens qui sont
très riches etc il faut qu'on arrive à
casser cette image et on essaye au
maximum de le faire une prochaine
journée dédiée aux nouveaux public aura
lieu au printemps 2023
à ma première fois l'opérat est un
dispositif qu'on trouve dans plusieurs
grandes villes de France l'avenir du
spectacle vivant face à la succession
des crises voilà le thème de notre débat
tout de suite avec Sylvie Robert bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice socialiste
d'Ille-et-Vilaine vice-présidente de la
Commission de la culture de l'éducation
de la communication et directrice de
l'Observatoire de la culture de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès j'accue également
Stéphanie le bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
acteur metteur en scène ancien directeur
du Théâtre de Paris des Bouffes
Parisiens de la Michodière vous avez été
également président à deux reprises
présidents de l'Association pour le
soutien au théâtre privé et vous mettez
en scène en ce moment la pièce femme en
colère au Théâtre de la pépinière qui
sera qui démarre au mois de janvier 19
janvier prochain Jacques nerf son
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
critique théâtre à l'Obs et puis au
masque la plume sur France Inter Mathieu
croissanto évidemment est resté à mes
côtés peut-être un point d'étape pour
commencer Sylvie Robert comment levons
le spectacle vivant le théâtre
aujourd'hui avec cette
crise énergétique qui fait suite à la
crise covid c'est vraiment je parlais de
succession des crises on est en plein
dedans
oui alors je vais pas dire qui va mal
parce que j'ai pas envie de commencer
par une note négative mais c'est vrai
que pose pandémie j'avais fait un
rapport à l'époque qui parlait
d'incertitude et de préoccupations
on a on a réouvert les théâtres quand
même et ils ont été fermés moi je ne
l'oublie pas
on arrive ouvert et et
ce qui s'est passé était inattendu
guère en Ukraine crise énergétique
inflation point d'indice du coup c'est
vrai que c'est c'est une rentrée je
dirais en tout cas une rentrée c'est une
situation nuancée c'est à dire que à la
fois le public revient alors très on en
parlera mais très différemment selon les
lieux selon les territoires selon les
l'offre qui est qui est donnée mais en
même temps on ne sait pas du tout si ça
va durer comment ça va durer il y a je
pense c'est l'incertitude et la crise
énergétique sur les budgets une façon
extrêmement forte et ça c'est la plus
grande préoccupation aujourd'hui
dans cette dans cette crise mais on va
aussi forcément parler de nos habitudes
de nos usages de de spectateurs qui ont
changé pour combien de temps je ne sais
pas Stéphane il est est-ce que j'essaye
on va essayer de pas être trop
catastrophiste mais je commence par les
questions un peu dures est-ce que cette
double crise là cette enchaînement ça va
jusqu'à menacer l'existence de certains
théâtres privés alors
je vais parler bien sûr que du privé
parce que je n'ai pas parlé pour le
théâtre public que je connais un peu
mais c'est pas spécialiste je dirais que
le théâtre privé a été formidablement
aidé pendant la période de pandémie il
faut quand même le dire comme de
multiples enfin beaucoup d'entreprises
donc ces aides ont permis de franchir le
cap de la pandémie 20 21
je dirais sans trop de dégâts les dégâts
ils sont en effet ce que c'est un triste
c'est-à-dire que
c'est on a tous cru un moment vraiment
que à partir du moment où on allait
rouvrir ça va être l'explosion du
bouchon de champagne et oui on a les se
rattraper tout le monde allait et quand
on interrogeait les gens qui disent mais
moi j'attends que ça Robert on était
tous sur les starting blocks prêts à
attendre le spectateur certains qu'il
allait revenir il est pas revenu
et c'est en fait je pense que la
et c'est ça c'est
malheureusement rebondi de de crise en
crise l'Ukraine et évidemment le pouvoir
d'achat fait que
à ce rythme là de crise en crise on perd
systématiquement et chaque fois un peu
de spectateur voilà alors faut pas faire
du catastrophisme non plus ce que je
pense que le spectateur il revient il
voit d'ailleurs que c'est pas si mal que
ça dans l'état privé la fréquentation
n'est pas si mauvaise que ça elle est
extrêmement différente
dans d'autres villes de France par
exemple alors de ce que je sais encore
ou de ce que je sais toujours oui c'est
très différent parce que d'abord
d'avoir le théâtre privé en région il y
en a beaucoup moins qu'à Paris
évidemment ce sont souvent des petits
salles
qui font des programmations tout à fait
honorable mais ils ont un public plus
habitué etc il y a pas les mêmes
difficultés de transport
quand même que nous celle que les
difficultés que nous connaissons à Paris
donc oui c'est très différente mais bon
ça dépend des grandes villes vous avez
raison mais quand même enfin Paris
particulier quand même c'est quand même
mourir c'est vraiment particulier mais
d'ailleurs on voit il y a une inversion
enfin pas une inversion mais on a changé
les horaires des spectacles beaucoup de
spectacles maintenant on lui a 20 heures
et non plus à 21h ou à 20h30 on
s'éloigne du 20h30 pour aller vers le
20H parce que rentrer chez soi quand on
habite Paris ou la grande ou la banlieue
c'est plus compliqué donc voilà donc il
y a des on va y revenir mais il y a déjà
évidemment vous vous restez pas le
secteur espagnol
je vais vous redonner la parole juste
après parce que voilà j'essaye de faire
en sorte que tout le monde puisse
parler puis le débat on a on a trois
quarts d'heure donc ça nous laisse un
peu de temps pour dire d'autre chose je
voudrais vous entendre évidemment avec
un
cette crise elle est malheureusement pas
nouvelle c'est à dire que il y a il y a
le covid il y a le la guerre en Ukraine
la crise du pouvoir d'achat comme on l'a
dit mais est-ce qu'on peut dire que le
théâtre vivant ou le spectacle vivant
n'est pas forcément très bien à avant la
crise covid
probablement depuis le 18e siècle donc
ça veut dire qu'il a fait preuve d'une
belle résilience oui oui mais c'est un
éternel moribond mais c'est vrai que ces
temps-ci a quand même des phénomènes
vraiment préoccupants et les gens de
théâtre et je les comprends ils essaient
un pays sont dans le déni d'ailleurs
qu'ils veulent pas tellement qu'on en
parle parce qu'ils ont peur que ça
accélère la catastrophe si on dit que ça
va mal ça va aller encore plus mal les
gens viendront pas etc c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que les gens de théâtre ne
rentre pas les recettes publiques comme
les gens de cinéma il y a pas moyen de
savoir
cela dit Bertrand ta main le directeur
du théâtre Montparnasse qui est
votre successeur non il est président du
syndicat des directeurs et il disait en
début de saison qui avait quand même 40
% voire plus de baisse de fréquentation
je ne vois pas comment une telle baisse
pourrait être à terme sans conséquence
il est évident qu'il y a des salles qui
finiront par fermer mais pardon de
mettre les pieds dans le plat mais il y
a pas alors là je vais faire et je
m'excuse auprès de noter les spectateurs
mais faire un focus sur Paris est-ce
qu'il y a pas aussi trop de théâtre trop
de salles de théâtre à Paris alors après
je dis ça c'est facile lesquels lesquels
on fait mais s'il y a pas trop trop
d'offres quoi trop de ça à Paris
Stéphanie de
plusieurs je crois qu'il y a une
mauvaise offre alors je vais vous donner
la parole Stéphanie l'aide d'abord et
puis ensuite pour rebondir sur ce que
disait Jacques je d'abord je pense que
les chiffres en effet du début de saison
était ce que Bertrand Bertrand avait
annoncé il se trouve que ça s'est
redresser depuis un peu donc on est à
moi 25 oui c'est à dire que en moyenne
c'est à peu près 20 le skate très très
observable c'est que vous n'avez plus de
spectacle qui marche moyennement bien ce
que on avait dans il y a encore quelques
années c'est à dire le spectacle qui
fait pas le plein mais qui
pivote gentiment on va dire ça n'existe
plus c'est soit c'est tout ou rien soit
vous marchez vraiment bien soit vous
n'avez personne dans la salle enfin
quand les personnes c'est très très peu
de monde dans la salle bon donc ça c'est
un phénomène
pas si nouveau que ça parce que comme je
n'ai changé tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est un phénomène qui s'est amorcé il y
a déjà avant la crise covie déjà donc
quelques pardon Jean-Paul américain de
cinéma blockbusters qui attirent un peu
mais qui sont pas forcément les affects
justement alors c'est là où il y a des
bonnes surprises
qui vivent les autres sales quoi mais
j'entends bien qui vide les oeuvres
disons que le bruit se répond très vite
et quand ça les gens n'ont plus ou les
moyens ou le temps y compris avant la
pandémie de se dire je vais perdre du
temps à une soirée où je vais passer
comme ça je veux être sûr du résultat
alors je repose la question je vous la
pose d'abord à vous et ensuite je
reviendrai est-ce qu'il y a trop de
salles de théâtre à Paris moi je ne
crois pas mais après trop de salles de
théâtre privée ou
écoutez moi j'ai je pense pas qu'il
fallait raisonner comme ça je crois que
après la question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
offre dans ces salles c'est plutôt ça et
on voit qu'aujourd'hui non seulement il
y a une modification des pratiques
culturelles de nos concitoyens c'est à
dire il réserve très tard il se pose la
question est-ce que ça va être bien
en tout cas beaucoup de ça l'ont
supprimé les abonnements c'est à dire
que on voit malheureusement un public
n'est pas revenu publique personne plus
âgées après la pandémie n'est pas
complètement revenue on voit d'autres
publics des jeunes et ça c'est plutôt
bien les jeunes actifs il y a une
modification des pratiques quand vous
êtes en télétravail toute la journée
vous n'êtes pas obligatoirement envie de
sortir le soir donc il va falloir
observer parce que là moi je peux pas
objectiver les choses tout de suite il
faut prendre un peu de distance mais on
sent qu'il y a une modification des
pratiques et une modification de la
façon dont on reçoit aussi les
spectacles c'est à dire que on est
beaucoup plus exigeant on écoute le
effectivement ce qui se passe en termes
de bouche à oreille je pense que il y
avait beaucoup moins toutes ces
questions avant la pandémie même si ça
commençait et ça s'est aggravé et moi je
pense que en termes de création et je
termine là de qualité de création
d'offres il faut voir ce qui est ce qui
est effectivement donné et après on peut
on peut se dire voilà qu'est-ce qui se
passe mais je suis pas sûr moi je dirais
pas qu'il y a moi je suis toujours ravie
quand il y a plein de théâtres
une offre
surtout si ça permet d'avoir une offre
complexe et de la créativité parce que
mais Jacques naçon la difficulté je
disais en titre que l'équation était
quasi impossible c'est que quand est-ce
que quand on est dans une situation de
crise comme celle que le le spectacle
vivant est en train de vivre est-ce
qu'on comprend pas moins de risques
encore moins de risques en matière de
création c'est on va vouloir s'appuyer
sur quelques acteurs qui plaisent aux
plus âgés parce qu'on sait qu'ils vont
les pas les faire venir en salle etc etc
je sais pas si on peut dire qu'ils
prennent moins de risques mais je crois
que cette crise surtout on la voyait
venir bien avant l'histoire du covid on
voyait surtout que le public ne se
renouvelait pas et moi je suis concerné
quand je vais dans les dans les théâtres
privés notamment parce que c'est
frappant mais on ne voit que des cheveux
blancs ou des crânes chauves comme le
mien et je suis j'ai l'impression d'être
très jeune quand j'y suis je fais
baisser la moyenne
ce sont des salles extrêmement vieilles
et c'est de ça que le théâtre est malade
aujourd'hui c'est de non mais il ne sait
pas renouvelé il n'a pas renouvelé ses
vedettes non plus on a vécu longtemps
sur des acteurs qui ont fini par mourir
et il n'y a pas eu une deuxième
génération de locomotives de ces acteurs
qui remplissaient les salles il y en a
plus aujourd'hui alors
peut-être que les directeurs de théâtre
est programmateurs ont trop longtemps
fonctionné sur ce système de végétaria
sans penser à ces aux auteurs et aux
pièces et je crois que j'avais vu une
enquête il y a pas très longtemps qui
montrait que les skisaient les
spectateurs de théâtre c'était les
histoires qu'on y racontait plus que les
acteurs
et plus que les mises en scène et pour
le coup la consommation culturelle a
changé parce que l'oeil des spectateurs
et qu'aujourd'hui confronté à une offre
culturelle abondante une nouvelle façon
de raconter enfin je pense évidemment
aux séries qu'on fait irruption sur
toutes les plateformes qui concurrent ce
cinéma mais qui concurrence aussi d'une
certaine façon une forme de
divertissement est-ce que le théâtre
c'est adapté dans son écriture à ces
nouveaux modes de narration à ce alors
je dis pas qu'il faut faire du haltan et
du suspense et du rebondissement mais
voilà est-ce que est-ce que à trop
écrire pour un public
d'habituer plutôt âgé ça me fait penser
un peu à la même crise que peuvent
traverser certains magazines une partie
de la presse qui a des vieux abonnés et
quand on continue on n'hésite toujours à
lâcher ses vieux abonnés pour les
récupérer un public nouveau parce que
souvent on lâche les abonnés et on
trouve personne de nouveau est-ce que
c'est pas ça aussi qui se joue
chez les auteurs chez les metteur en
scène chez les patrons de ça dans
Stéphane il est alors écoutez les les
auteurs je connais bien ce que j'en ai
quand même pas mal et j'en ai lu pas mal
mais
pardon ce qui est vous avez raison
mais tout est une question de il y a pas
une vérité qui s'impose les auteurs se
sont adaptés si vous regardez
aujourd'hui la durée moyenne d'un
spectacle elle est beaucoup plus courte
que ce qui se faisait il y a 20 ans vous
ne voyez plus d'entracte les actes dit
de présentation on a des auteurs
célèbres qui avaient des grands actes de
présentation etc mais même pas à 500
sans remonter à Molière bon aujourd'hui
non on est immédiatement souvent dans
l'action
et ça c'est aussi en effet vous avez
annoncé l'arrivée des séries
du cinéma en général qui a changé les
les modes d'écriture
si on part aux auteurs les auteurs ils
sont happés aussi
pour écrire par le pour le cinéma
c'est un joli débouché quand on est
auteur donc on va peut-être avoir moins
tendance à écrire parce que c'est
compliqué d'écrire pour le théâtre on
n'est pas sûr d'être joué on va gagner
beaucoup moins d'argent enfin bon vous
voyez déjà pas sûr d'être lu parce que
ils envoient leur texte les auteurs et
souvent ils n'ont aucune réponse parce
que beaucoup de théâtres sont paramètres
à une plateforme mais bon oui ils sont
mieux organisés le cinéma
beaucoup mieux organismes sont plus
riches c'est vrai et et je peux dire
parce que j'ai vécu expert expérience
c'est à dire qu'en fait selon ton
réalise pas c'est qu'il y a énormément
de gens qui écrivent pour le théâtre
mais plein mais ils écrivent l'histoire
qui leur est arrivé à eux il y a 25 ans
que le jour où ils ont eu la naissance
de leur premier enfant qui n'est pas une
histoire passionnante heureuse mais pas
non plus de quoi voilà peut-être pas
faire une heure et demie
du monde voilà bon donc faisons le tri
c'est ça alors ce problème du tri est
absolument invraisemblable moi je je
fais avoir des comités de lecture ça
coûte de l'argent il faut que ce soit
des gens de confiance dont on sait que
l'oeil et la lecture sera voilà et qui
nous remonte moi j'ai essayé de faire un
comité de lecture ça a échoué au bout de
quelques mois parce que je me remontait
des choses qui me tombaient des mains
donc j'allais refouiller voyez je voyais
passer un truc intéressant j'ai pourquoi
vous me l'avez pas ah bah non ça nous a
pas paru intéressant enfin bon bref
voilà c'est c'est très compliqué le
comité de lecture on va revenir à votre
rapport parce que finalement Mathieu
l'évoquais le le changement de nos
habitudes de de spectateur de
consommateurs de de spectacle de
divertissement de de culture il est
évidemment lié à la crise covid Quentin
calmé vous pouvez nous rejoindre tout de
suite sur ce plateau rebonsoir
très belle entrée théâtrale le rideau
sous on va donc retrouver plusieurs
rapports d’ailleurs mener ici au Sénat
pour et faire le bilan de l'action de
l'État auprès du secteur de la création
après la crise voilà le Parlement
contrôle l'action de l'État on a donc lu
avec attention vos rapports qui
reviennent un petit peu sur toutes les
aides par exemple qui ont été proposées
depuis mince 2020 à tous ces acteurs du
spectacle vivant on va aller voir on
parle par exemple de l'activité
partielle ou encore d'un son de
solidarité les exonérations ouais de
paiement des cotisations sociales les
prêts garantis par l'État ou encore
l'année blanche pour les intermittents
alors quelques jours après le
remaniement on avait vu sur votre
plateau Thomas Roselyne Bachelot faire
un peu le bilan de ces deux années au
ministère de la Culture écouter un
résumé de ce qu'elle disait sur ces deux
années d'action
que j'ai voulu d'abord j'étais en
mission commando je l'ai considéré comme
ça 22 mois 682 jours pour pour sauver
pour sauver la culture ce que nous avons
fait un partout il y a des structures
qui ont fermé dans le cinéma on n'avait
pas une seule salle de cinéma qui a
fermé enfin le titre Le tête moderne à
Londres à licencié 40 % de son personnel
il y a pas un licenciement dans nos
structures publiques etc c'est quand
même assez assez extraordinaire et puis
j'ai voulu aussi que les choses
continuent je n'ai pas fait que de
l'urgence voilà un mot sur les budgets
de la culture sur cet aspect du budget
de la culture qui est en hausse depuis
2021 on voit les crédits pour 2021 ils
sont à 861 millions d'euros ce pour 2022
915 millions d'euros auxquels sont venus
s'ajouter donc 400 millions d'euros du
plan de relance et c'est ça aussi vous
avez analysé au Sénat dans un second
rapport vous avez regardé qui était les
principaux bénéficiaires de ce plan de
relance on trouve les théâtres privés et
de variétés en première position ils ont
cueilli recueilli près de 40% du plan de
relance viennent ensuite les grands
opérateurs internationaux de la création
à l'Opéra national de Paris la Comédie
Française ou encore la Grande Halle de
la Villette et enfin seul 20% des
crédits vous l'avez dit dans votre
rapport sont déconcentrés c'est-à-dire
situés en dehors de Paris avec les aides
liés au plan de relance qui vont
s'arrêter à la fin de l'année 2022
Thomas qui inquiète quand on sait que
les structures sont aussi percutées par
la hausse des prix de l'énergie
effectivement merci
Quentin pour ces explications Sylvie
Robert il y a un peu un une sorte
d'effet ciseaux c'est à dire que là il
faut commencer à rembourser notamment
les prêts garantis par l'État pour pour
certains théâtres et ils doivent le
faire alors que il y a moins de
spectacles on a fait le constat il y a
moins de spectateurs qui viennent et il
y a un coût de l'énergie qui est qui
devient vertigine donc ça c'est
indéniable qu'il y a une augmentation
des crédits donc ça on ne peut pas ne
pas le dire et d'ailleurs je le dis dans
mes rapports pour autant quand je
parlais de rentrer nuancée ou en tout
cas d'inquiétude c'est que l'effet
ciseaux entre la hausse de l'énergie
mais qui va être très impactant pour
beaucoup d'établissements ils sont en
train aujourd'hui de beaucoup ont déjà
mesuré les factures ça va être multiplié
par trois quatre voire c'est assez je
vous parle même pas des grands
opérateurs nationaux
ça va être assez vertigineux de grands
opérateurs nationaux c'est à dire les
grands établissements imaginez bien que
des grands opéras etc ça la vie plus
importante
je ne sais plus combien de de multiplier
par 7 je crois donc c'est vrai que c'est
énorme en plus la Villette donc de toute
façon l'effet ciseaux il va être là et
c'est vrai que entre ces hausses de
coups inflation aussi le contexte le
contexte vous le disiez très justement
de de personnes qui certes reviennent
mais on ne sait pas vont pouvoir
continuer à venir parce qu'elles sont
les sens parce que parce que voilà la
question de l'offre de l'exigence des
modifications des pratiques tout ça fait
qu'à un moment oui moi je parle de temps
de l'incertitude on est encore dans ce
temps d'incertitude aujourd'hui qui
préoccupe et qui inquiète est-ce que ça
touche tous types de spectacle est-ce
que si bien le stand up les humoristes
les comédies musicales ont la même
désaffection ou subissent la même crise
que les pièces de théâtre en tant que
tel je pense que le stand-up non mais
bon je crois que ça marche très bien je
crois que ça marche beaucoup ça marche
beaucoup mieux parce que ce sont des
fois
c'est ce que ce qu'il faut voir et ce
qui me disent il y a quelque chose qui
me donne qui plaise aux jeunes
actuellement qui m'inquiète c'est que il
ne faudrait pas soit privé que dans le
théâtre public qu'à un moment on
différencie les spectacles en fonction
du temps par exemple spectacle et ce
serait terrible c'est à dire si dure une
heure on y va s'il dure trois heures
c'est juste pas possible et moi
j'entends encore autour de moi non c'est
un peu différent je pense que le cinéma
c'est différent il y a d'autres facteurs
qui expliquent aujourd'hui la
désinfection et ça c'est un vrai sujet
combien de temps ça dure est-ce que
enfin la question du temps aujourd'hui
quand vous allez un spectacle de théâtre
beaucoup maintenant me demandent combien
de temps il dure et quand j'ai 3 heures
tu vas avoir un spectacle de trois
heures oui à il y a un autre acte mais
voilà la question du temps et du coup le
stand up se déforme très courte rapide
on peut s'ennuyer je reste poli dans un
spectacle de stand-up et être passionnés
par un spectacle de 3 heures évidemment
mais bon c'est en tout cas des facteurs
qui va falloir regarder avec beaucoup de
d'acuité parce que derrière c'est la
question de la diversité c'est la
question sur l'ensemble de la nature
comme vous le disiez si on va
l'adaptation
quand tu es Avignon vous présenter comme
j'ai vu cet un spectacle de 13h et un
autre de 10 heures il est évident que il
y a des gens qui viendront oui mais vous
écartez toute une tranche de population
notamment les gens qui travaillent parce
qu'il y a avant les gens d'Avignon
pouvaient aller au spectacle aussi la
c'est hors de question ils peuvent pas
se mobiliser un temps un temps aussi
long et je pense que ça ça détourne du
théâtre ça le rend un peu inabordable ça
fait peur aux jeunes ce genre de choses
alors c'est intéressant parce que
justement on avait prévu d'écouter une
réaction de d'Olivier pic était encore
le directeur du festival d'Avignon parce
que c'était à l'ouverture de de la
dernière édition début juillet ou lui
mettait en avant un dispositif pour
faciliter l'accès notamment aux jeunes
promotion du théâtre populaire en écoute
Olivier
les salles de théâtre et les salles de
cinéma en considérablement souffert du
covid nous notre billetterie affiche au
beau fixe mais c'est vrai que c'est un
cas particulier à nous tenons notre
légitimité du public je tiens à rappeler
que d'ailleurs les moins de 25 ans paye
10 euros à Avignon donc si on me demande
quelle est la définition du théâtre
populaire j'ai pas besoin de dire autre
chose c'est aussi simple que ça alors ça
ouvre une question que la question du
prix des places Jacques mercon je reste
avec vous je vais vous donner la parole
juste après Stéphane mais c'est
compliqué le prix des places parce que
si on rend le théâtre trop bon marché on
le dévalorise et d'ailleurs on
remarquera que les jeunes n'hésite pas à
payer des sommes très importantes pour
aller au concert rock aux trucs comme ça
et donc quand même
un choix qu'on fait en fonction de ce
qu'on a envie de voir ou pas alors et
puis mais d'autre part il est vrai que
les prix actuellement pratiqués dans les
aides privées en tout cas aux bonnes
place rendent impossible
ces spectacles moyens dans Stéphane
parlait tout à l'heure on pouvait
prendre un riche quand on va voir là
effectivement le prix des meilleures
places
dans certains théâtre presque 80 euros
la place
les plus élevés
à voir à mal voir c'est-à-dire que la
télévision et le cinéma nous habituent à
voir parfaitement un spectacle et là
accepter de voir à moitié de de très
haut etc c'est maintenant les
spectateurs n'y sont plus habitués sont
pas disposés à accepter ce genre de ces
conditions et d'ailleurs ce sont les
places les plus difficiles à remplir oui
les places qui sont les les où on voit
le moins bien
et alors qu'elles sont moins chers on
peut on peut comprendre je vous redonne
la parole sur la question du prix des
places à un élément au dossier en
quelque sorte puisqu'on a démarré ce
débat par un reportage à l'Opéra je vous
propose là tiens la grille tarifaire de
pouvoir Carmen à l'Opéra Bastille à 10
catégories de place qui vont de 15 à 209
euros Carmen qui jusqu'au 25 février
mais il n'y a plus aucune place au
premier prix là si on en a regardé si on
veut acheter des places aujourd'hui
c'est 50 euros minimum pour pour aller
voir Carmen Stéphanie le
je reviens à l'équation impossible
c'est-à-dire que je sais pas si le fait
de baisser le prix des places peut être
un moyen de faire revenir du public et
notamment un public plus jeune puisqu'on
a un problème de vieillissement de des
spectateurs de théâtre mais quand on
quand on doit payer des factures qui
augmentent quand on fabrique ce que je
veux dire c'est peut-être pas le moment
de baisser le prix des places peut-on le
faire est-ce qu'il y a des théâtres
privés qui sont dans l'incapacité totale
de le faire au risque de déplaire à
Olivier puis le théâtre privé depuis des
années fait pour le public de moins de
25 ans jusqu'à 25 ans publie tout
étudiant mais voilà
chômeur etc les places à 10 euros
d'ailleurs c'est une compensation de la
ville de Paris qui nous reverse 5 euros
qui reverse le directeur 5 euros ce qui
fait la place à 15 euros mais c'est une
subvention en fait que ces places à 10
euros pour les jeunes ça marche
mais ça marche
quand même insuffisamment pour
renouveler le public c'est ça la
difficulté c'est que ils vont aller voir
en effet alors nous on a l'arbre qui
cache la forêt c'est michelique c'est
Alexis Michalik Alexis Michalik
effectivement auteur de hauteur de
théâtre que ce soit Edmond
et d'autres spectacles qui se jouent
depuis des années bon allez-y michelique
très jeune metteur en scène
jeune auteur je ne connais rien
exactement fait des spectacles
d'ailleurs tout à fait formidables c'est
vrai bon et c'est un peu public jeune ce
public jeune aujourd'hui on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il se redirige après
avoir vu un spectacle de michelique vers
d'autres spectacles du privé c'est un
fait ils vont voir du Michalik
et je vous dis les places à 10 euros
donc le prix de la place je dis pas et
en effet oui ils vont aller voir un
stand-up de XYZ où ils vont payer 60 ou
70 euros ou un concert donc je dis pas
que ça ne joue pas le prix de la place
mais pas autant qu'on le pense c'est
c'est sur le désir que ça se passe voilà
et on revient à la question de la de la
création et
le désir et de l'adaptation publique un
élément pour rester sur cette question
du du prix finalement le le passe
culture qui permet un accès aux plus
jeunes au spectalisant mais pas
seulement au musée à la culture en
général il s'ouvre désormais désormais
pardon dès l'âge de 15 ans ça représente
vous le voyez un budget de plus de 208
millions d'euros pour l'année prochaine
avec une hausse de 9 millions et demi
Sylvie Robert là aussi bon on va pas
expliquer tout le système de du Pass
Culture j'ai un peu compliqué à 30 euros
à 15 ans et puis ensuite bon bref on
peut bénéficier jusqu'à 24 mois après
après 18 ans et ça peut monter jusqu'à
300 euros si j'ai bien tout compris
est-ce que ça rajeunit vraiment le le
public des salles ou le public des
musées alors quand le Pass Culture a été
créé moi j'avais appelé ça un chèque
culture qui était tout simplement un
chèque donné aux jeunes pour aller voir
ce qu'il connaissait déjà et d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui se passe sur la part
individuelle ce qu'on appelle la part
individuel ils vont alors on a beaucoup
parlé des mangas pour les librairies
vous savez après j'espère qu'ils
achètent d'autres ouvrages me disent les
libraires mais bon les mangas la musique
les concerts et puis aussi beaucoup le
cinéma c'est le théâtre quand on
regardait les fréquentations ils n'y
vont pas spontanément
ils n'y vont pas spontanément parce que
tout simplement dans leur parcours voilà
de jeunes on leur a peut-être pas pour
certains un certain nombre d'entre eux
ouvert les portes d'un théâtre ou en
tout cas on leur a pas dit tiens tu peux
avoir tu peux aller au théâtre et c'est
là que moi je reprochais beaucoup au
Pass Culture de naître qu'un chèque
maintenant il y a la part collective
c'est intéressant c'est une bonne
évolution qui va permettre par collectif
c'est ce que vous avez dit c'est à dire
que en fait c'est au lycée et maintenant
ça va être au collège c'est à dire qu'en
fait ils ont un peu d'argent pour
pouvoir aller
eux-mêmes
enfin voir un spectacle ou faire ou ce
qu'ils le souhaitent en fait et l'école
enfin l'établissement scolaire peut
aussi bénéficier bénéficie d’argent et
donc va organiser éventuellement et
ouvrir un peu le le l'horizon
ce soit un des leviers pour ce qu'on
appelle l'éducation artistique et
culturelle qui permettent de travailler
sur des parcours de jeunes et au bout
d'un parcours effectivement
a découvert un spectacle de marionnette
bah oui ça existe ou un spectacle de il
aura la possibilité librement en toute
en toute discernement c'est ce que j'ai
de pouvoir choisir il est quand même
rare que à l'échelle d'une scolarité un
enfant un adolescent n'est jamais été au
théâtre accompagné beaucoup plus rare en
tout cas
que on est quelqu'un qui est dans les 40
qui a une scolarité dans les années
50-60 il a pas au théâtre comme on voit
on emmène aujourd'hui que ce soit pour
voir des petites pièces des grandes
pièces
faut pouvoir organiser la sortie au
théâtre qui se montent c'est quelque
chose qui existe dans l'imaginaire des
enfants ce qui est compliqué c'est
pourquoi ça n'accroche pas derrière
est-ce que c'est on revient cette
question de l'offre est-ce que les
acteurs sont trop âgés les pièces sont
trop vieilles ou trop élitistes enfin il
y a peut-être une question qui veut se
poser moi la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce que d'autres pays sont
confrontés à cette désaffection du
théâtre et si oui que certains y ont
répondu et comment peut-être Stéphane il
est là mais moi j'ai toujours été frappé
mais peut-être que je me trompe mais
l'Angleterre par exemple Royaume-Uni et
vont au théâtre ils vont voir des
spectacles si vous allez enfin en tout
cas il y a encore quelques années 4-5
ans 5 6 ans que j'y suis partout
retourné mais à cette époque là j'étais
très frappé d'aller voir des pièces
alors ça pouvait être des grands
spectacles c'est cher c'est très cher
elle n'était pas seulement les comédies
musicales donc je parle pas que des
comédies musicales des grandes comédies
musicales bon sur le western non non je
parle au théâtre ou même en tournée je
me souviens être allé voir un spectacle
à basse bon c'est
le théâtre était plein et de gens plutôt
jeunes voilà
je pense que on est sur aussi un autre
phénomène c'est l'éducation culturelle à
l'école c'est à dire que les petits
Anglais
il chante il danse et ils ont le théâtre
c'est quasiment obligatoire à l'école
presque donc ils ont une culture de ça
et et voilà et on ne l'a pas nous
propose d'écouter on a on a écouté
Bachelot dans la chronique de Quentin
calmé mais on va réécouter l'ancienne
ministre de la Culture donc elle était
présente sur ce plateau c'était au mois
de juin de mémoire effectivement juste
après le remaniement et donc elle
parlait de cette question de de
l'éducation à la culture écoutons
Roselyne Bachelot
la 15% des gens pardon qui sont sur une
culture numérique exclusive qui ne vont
à rien d'autre ni musée ni peu rien et
que c'est majoritairement des gens moins
de 40 ans et ça faut pas se faire qui ne
lisent jamais un livre il faut pas se
faire d'illusions quand on a pas lu un
livre avant 40 ans je vous garantis
qu'on ne lira pas 50 alors bon voilà
l'argument de Roselyne Bachelot je
propose un autre point de vue celui de
Steven Stéphane pardon fuenkinos
réalisateur qui est tellement du jury du
festival new-y images et créateur d'un
projet en réalité augmentée écouter le
présenter cette idée
est-ce que c'est un spectacle est-ce que
c'est du cinéma est-ce que c'est du
théâtre est-ce que c'est une
installation muséale en fait c'est tout
ça à la fois et à un moment donné où la
salle devient un endroit un peu déserté
on le sait par les spectateurs je pense
que sans dire que c'est l'avenir mais
c'est définitivement une clé vers vers
une autre manière d'apprécier la fiction
je pense alors voilà il nous reste 5
minutes dans ce débat et on va on va
voir et je voudrais vous entendre et ce
qu'il faut forcément opposer je les fais
un peu caricaturalement là mais opposer
le numérique est finalement le livre
même si on peut lire évidemment sur une
tablette mais le livre ou le spectacle
vivant Jacques Merson mais la Comédie
Française a prouvé pendant le
confinement et au contraire ça pouvait
être très utile de se servir
effectivement du numérique et j'en
parlais très récemment avec
Eric ruffle l'administrateur général et
il me disait que plus ça leur avait
apporté de nouveaux spectateurs que
c'était très positif parce que certains
au début dans la troupe se sont dit mais
alors ils vont plus venir au théâtre si
c'est une vraie question si on passe par
hablage reprend lorsque des iPhone Kino
c'est on passe par un casque de réalité
augmentée mais alors si on passe par un
casque de ça sert plus rien d'aller en
salle vous voyez ce que je veux dire ce
sera jamais du théâtre non plus et
justement les ceux qui ont goûté le
théâtre à la télévision
d'aller voir d'aller voir ce que c'est
et au fond c'est c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé à nous aussi dans ma génération
on a découvert essentiellement théâtre à
la télévision dans des émissions comme
au théâtre ce soir qui était pas
forcément la crème de la crème mais bon
et du théâtre populaire et ça nous a
donné envie d'aller après au théâtre
donc je pense pas que ce soit
antinomique Sylvie Robert sur cette
cette question finalement ce que disait
Bachelot il y a est-ce qu'il y a un
moment c'est trop tard quoi on a pas on
est que dans l'univers numérique on n'a
pas lu un livre à 40 ans ou à 50 ans et
on peut un moment lire à 50 ans parce
que il peut y avoir une association qui
enfin voilà dans la vie je pense qu'il
faut tout le temps être optimiste et se
dire que la culture la connaissance et
en tout cas à la portée de tout le monde
c'est en tout cas ce qui me porte et ce
qui m'anime depuis tant d'années moi
j'appelle ça la réalité augmentée c'est
à dire que je ne pose jamais et je pense
qu'au contraire ça peut jouer comme une
réalité augmentée c'est-à-dire comme une
envie de pouvoir effectivement il faut
avoir peut-être sur sa tablette mais
d'aller en salle je pense que c'est
c'est il faut pas opposer et tous les
moyens sont bons tous les moyens après
moi ce qui m'interroge tout le temps
c'est le contenu c'est la question du
contenu mais parce que c'est les
vecteurs d'aller en physique ou alors de
regarder à la télé une pièce ou au
cinéma maintenant les opéras enfin tout
ça fait que si ça peut donner envie et
si ça moi je trouve que c'est plutôt
bien et moi j'appelle ça de la réalité
augmentée souvenez-vous quand la musique
on s'est dit il y a plus de concert en
live parce que maintenant on va pouvoir
l'écouter etc c'est pas vrai et
maintenant les artistes ils font
finalement ceux qui réussissent c'est
ceux qui font du live c'est pas ceux qui
sont sur Spotify ou sur Deezer Stéphanie
layl sur un spectacle de théâtre
aujourd'hui souvent il intègre de la
vidéo il a enfin voilà il est il a déjà
eu cette cette adaptation c'est c'est
pas nouveau j'enfonce une porte ouverte
en disant ça mais jusqu'où on peut
entremêler comme ça les technologies
numériques au spectacle vivant pour
peut-être répondre à ce de moi ce besoin
donc on évoquait de
régénération créative en quelque sorte
toutes les techniques vont elles
évoluent elles avancent et en effet
matin il y a l'utilisation des vidéos
mais ça reste dans le cadre de la scène
dans le cadre de du spectacle du
spectacle avec des spectateurs face à
face le principe du théâtre
un défi pour les comédiens qui consiste
à jouer à la fois pour la caméra qui les
filme et pour la salle de théâtre c'est
pas si facile mais moi je crois que moi
je suis comme un optimisme forcené sur
le théâtre et puis c'est l'histoire
prouve que rien ne l'a rien n'a jamais
détruit le théâtre depuis
2000 ans rien n'a jamais dit quand le
cinéma est arrivé tout le monde a cru
que quand la radio est arrivée on a cru
que quand la télévision faisait du du
théâtre au théâtre ce soir on a cru que
ça allait vider les salles ça les a
plutôt remplis aujourd'hui on parle du
numérique on parle bon ok oui il y a des
crises il y a des moments de creux et il
y a des moments de creux parce qu'on n'a
pas les grands auteurs non plus c'est
vrai ou peut-être pas trouvé encore les
les meilleurs moyens de communiquer avec
le spectateur d'une manière générale
mais moi je suis pas je pense que ce
sont des phases rien d'autre et que
pendant que je nous parlez pardon mais
on voit des images du spectacle de
Benjamin Millepied
voilà après ce sont des phases ce sont
des moments et puis ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut pas regarder analyser c'est
de comprendre et trouver les meilleures
solutions mais il est pas mort le
théâtre il est pas mort le théâtre merci
beaucoup allez au théâtre allez voir des
spectacles vivants je ne peux pas
terminer ce débat sans dire cela et
notamment la pièce que vous mettez en
scène et bien d'autres femmes en colère
oui mais puisque vous êtes là autant la
mettre en valeur ce sera au Théâtre de
la Pépinière à partir du 19 janvier
prochain merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat et je vous dis à demain on
sera donc depuis le salon des mers de
France émission spéciale de Smart impact
et puis l'invité politique de la
matinale demain 8h Christian Estrosi le
maire de Nice bonne soirée à toutes et à
tous